[music playing]
(SINGING) God's gonna
trouble the water.
"Water and Power--
A California Heist" is a
feature-length documentary
about the politics of
water in California.
California officials are
putting mandatory restrictions
on water use in place.
MARK ARAX: Water
has become gold.
In the midst of this
drought, agriculture
has recorded record crops.
So the question becomes
how they manage to do that.
MARINA ZENOVICH: The
California aqueduct
was set up by Governor Pat
Brown, Jerry Brown's father.
REPORTER: A river
700 miles long.
The largest project
ever undertaken
by an American state.
MARINA ZENOVICH: We have
an artificial river running
through this desert state.
There are so many different
layers in this world of water.
There are a lot of
manipulations behind the scenes
that we know nothing about.
And our film focuses
on a series of meetings
where a water bank
ended up getting out
of the hands of the
state of California
and into the hands of
some private individuals.
[cash register]
There was nothing illegal
about what they did,
because most of what
they do is legal
because they write the rules.
It's an expose of
greed, basically.
So I hope people will just kind
of say, wow, this is happening
and we need to band together
and try to fix this.
[music playing]